porque una facción del partido
republicano considera que esta comisión
investigadora es una completa farsa no
existe una necesidad real de llegar al
fondo de este hecho que fue grave para
la historia política de eeuu
bueno lo más importante es cómo es su
pieza destacó es de tener un tipo de
balance político no que sea un juicio
político en contra del partido
republicano pero es importante escuchar
de estos oficiales y qué y qué fue lo
que ellos
experimentaron ese día eso es sumamente
importante porque lo que importa y el
pueblo americano y la prensa
internacional en sí quiere saber qué fue
lo que sucedió y por qué se llevaron a
cabo este tipo de violencia que nunca es
aceptable
este reporte esta primera reunión de
esta comisión y también los hechos a lo
largo de estos meses han dejado en
evidencia que hay divisiones dentro del
partido republicano por un lado pues hay
representantes que han estado allí en
esta comisión y que están participando y
quienes están apoyando la labor y hay
otros políticos republicanos que han
dicho que simplemente se trata de un
reporte fallido y respaldan la teoría
del expresidente trump
bueno el presidente de trump es él el
líder del partido republicanos le guste
a quien le guste eso es una realidad y
entonces
muchos republicanos lo apoyan una
mayoría enorme hay otros republicanos
que no apoyan a la policía al tono del
presidente trump aunque sean
republicanos porque piensan que no es un
tono de diplomacia un tono político pero
la realidad es que el presidente de
trump sigue siendo el líder del partido
república tener esta opinión de como
analista a usted qué conclusiones se
espera de esta comisión y de esta
investigación usted cree que esto sí va
a ayudar a cerrar esa división política
que está presentando eeuu o por el
contrario ayudará a profundizar aún más
la división que hay en este país
pues mire yo lo que pienso es que si
como analista que si se lleva a cabo una
audiencia el profesional en donde ambas
partes pueden presentar sus puntos y
ceei es una audiencia sin ninguna
influencia política es difícil porque
estamos hablando de de la política en el
congreso de eeuu entonces yo creo que sí
va a tener una legitimidad al contrario
pienso que no tendrá legitimidad y todo
se ve como un acto político en contra
del presidente de trump y en contra los
republicanos así que está en la mano del
presidente el señor thompson es un
hombre balanceado y está en la mano de
todos aquellos miembros del congreso del
comité
que enfocan este este tópico la realidad
es que la violencia nunca es aceptable y
la violencia en el capitolio obviamente
de los eeuu no es aceptable no me
recuerdo bien cuando los policías nos
protegieron yo estuve presente en el
capitolio durante los ataques del 9/11 y
los policías siempre han estado
presentes dispuesto a dar la vida para
salvar a los congresistas y actos
asesores